ils avertissent qu'ils sont là pour un
moment les employés municipaux de basse
pointe et leur syndicat cgtm soem
débrayent depuis ce matin pour soutenir
un agent le directeur des services
techniques
gary jean zéphirin embauché par le maire
de basse pointe au début de son mandat
avait pourtant une carrière prometteuse
mais il est aujourd'hui sous le coup
d'une enquête pénale et d'un
licenciement
la simultanéité des démarches dérange le
syndicat il n'y a pas de procédure
interne montrant qu'il ya une zac une
faute administrative
or la qualification des fautes qu'elle
potes qui sont très graves sont de
l'ordre du pénal au moins j'aurais pu
attendre qu'il y ait une décision
quelconque un revenant du monde
juridique judiciaire avant de pouvoir se
dire aussi nous avons un préavis de
grève en cours depuis un certain temps
nous avons négocié certaines le point
tous les points ont connu les avancées
sur ce point là obama ne voulait rien
entendre
ce matin le jeune directeur était
convoqué pour son entretien préalable
ce qu'on lui reproche notamment ses
d'avoir donné un des portables de la
ville à son épouse en échange se défend
t-il il utiliser son téléphone personnel
pour travailler
peu importe enfin porte les sexes apps a
apporté de bon pour la collectivité pour
elle je lui ai demandé
justement quel préjudice ça a porté à la
collectivité parce que le travail était
fait et peut-être mieux plus rapidement
elle m'a dit que c'est la relation de
confiance qui a été rompu
mais ce ne serait pas le seul dossier où
l'on reproche au directeur d'avoir
utilisé sa position pour obtenir des
avantages supplémentaires et la gestion
des fonds publics doit être exemplaire
estime le maire s'il s'agissait de mon
agent personnel de les données
personnelles j'ai fait ce que je vais
avec mais à partir du moment où moi
aussi je suis cadre de l'exécution du
budget je suis garante de la gestion des
fonds publics est la personne qui vous
parle a eu dans le passé une délégation
de signatures financières aux signes et
des millions d'allocations aux chômeurs
et mais je peux vous assurer qu'on ne
peut pas me faire le reproche d'un autre
chien centimes d'euro à basse-pointe
l'ambiance est en tout cas souvent
échauffés autour de la mairie
le syndicat affirme que d'autres agents
font l'objet de sanctions expéditive les
problèmes politiques viennent aussi s'y
mêler avec une récente démission de
toute l'opposition au conseil municipal
[Musique]